this is where parents have to be very
careful when you just say [ __ ] that
you're not fully confident in and then
it ends up being wrong for all the
parents over the last 15 years that told
their kids get off social media you'll
never make money on that and then all
these people did you're gonna have a
problem for them to listen to you more
in the future it's when you tell your
kids tried and true things around
humanity and like how people deal with
each other that then end up being true
that starts to build credibility having
my parents trust me to have my own
career that I have a voice in I think
was something that made me respect what
they had to say so much more because
they trusted me and they respected what
I had to say it's the opposite of what I
am scared about every day which is
parents continue to overcodile children
and what they think they're doing is
helping and what they're doing is
they're signaling to the kid I don't
think you're capable of doing [ __ ]
without my help which then renders that
kid to not be confident